Now that we've got a sense of our
critical questions and that they've
all been answered, we need to consider
how many times they've been answered.
How many users do we need to test with
to feel confident in our results?
Luckily for
us, it turns out that we really only
need a few people to get good data.
Each prototype should be
shown to three to five users,
in order to catch most of
the issues in the design.
One of the most fascinating articles
in user research by Jakob Nielsen,
shows that on average a study of 3 users
will find upwards of 60% of the issues
with your prototype.
A study of 5 users will average
upwards of 75% of the issues.
In either case, that's enough to get
a sense of how the prototype did, and
further research gives
vastly diminishing returns.
The art of prototyping is
not the art of extensive QA.
It is a waste of time to find 100% of
the issues in an app design
that you plan on throwing out.
When you have three to five users
being asked the same questions,
you start to see trends.
User B will probably find some
of the same flaws as user A, and
these flaws should be
counted as more glaring.
When you're thinking about how to
weigh data from various users,
it's useful to go back to how
critical the question was.
If a critical part of
the app is going wrong for
multiple users, you have a problem.
When you're thinking about how to
weigh data from various users,
it's useful to go back to
how critical a question was.
If a critical part of
the app is going wrong for
multiple users, you have a problem.
If a less critical part of the app
is going wrong for multiple users,
you're probably still fine and can iron
that out in meeting fidelity prototypes.
So, for our app, we'll want to bucket
feedback from all of our users.
In to some style of yes or
no by question.
That will allow us to actually make
a decision about our app moving forward.
You'll note that we've only done
research with two users for our study.
That's because when we
include your user testing,
we'll have a full study of three users.
In the next node, we'll decide whether
to make another Lo-Fi prototype, or
whether to move on to
a medium fidelity one.